tonight North Las Vegas planning
Commissioners passed a new plan that
would redevelop the land that was once
occupied by both the Texas Station and
Fiesta Rancho casinos developers want to
build a mixed-use commercial and
residential area that's family oriented
now along with homes it would also
include Shopping Center restaurants and
a brand new ice skating rink it would
also retain the current parking garage
that's already there it now heads to
city council for full approval
developers hope to start building in the
second quarter of next year the FAA will
also have to sign off on the project
though due to how close it is to the
north Las Vegas Airport